At one point i was supposed to be in it yeah there
was going to be another peter parker like it was
like a scene in a train station or something
and and like it was it was going to be like a
like an easter egg i was going to walk through the
background and say like hey kid or something and
never happened i'm heartbroken um but i'm just
excited for us to introduce miles into our own
universe one day i think that's going to be
really cool should be wild yeah should be a wild
wild time tom um can you tell us about the spider
verse honestly mate i'm sick of this spider verse
i'm the only spider-man it's me only one
there ever is and ever will greg sorry
welcome back everyone it's charlie this is
going to be my new spider-man 3 marvel video
about miles morales we have a clip of tom holland
talking about introducing miles morales into the
mcu so i'll explain what's going on because an
audition tape for what seems like miles morales
just leaked online if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos of
course i'll be doing more spider-man 3 bonus
videos while they're filming the movie tom
holland has already been posting stuff from
behind the scenes it looks like he's so tired
he's getting ready to pass out sitting down but
big stuff first number five recently an audition
for miles morales showed up online then after
it circulated a little bit was quickly deleted
bloggers caught it and were able to figure
out what was going on in the scenes though
it was seemingly for spider-man 3 or
possibly another spider-man spin-off movie
when a slightly older looking version of miles
morales was delivering food for a restaurant
and then talking about being a big spider-man
stand getting stopped by cops who really hated
spider-man which kind of tracks with what's
going on at the end of spider-man far from home
with all the law enforcement agencies around the
world hating spider-man then in the second part of
that audition video he was supposedly speaking
with his family while a news broadcast in the
background nearby was playing back footage of a
crime scene talking about spider-man being found
dead after a battle at a museum so a lot of people
saw that and thought that the actor looked like he
was in his early 20s and sort of connected the
dots that if spider-man were supposed to be dead
in that version of whatever scene he was filming
how could this be happening on the mcu version
of earth so if the audition video was really
for a new spider-man movie as is speculated it
would have just been more live-action spider-verse
easter eggs like they're planning on introducing
a version of miles morales that's much older
from another universe so that they can do both
tom hall and spider-man and miles morales at the
same time without having to kill off tom holland's
mcu spider-man we still haven't seen him cross
over with venom face off against a full-blown
sinister six team and they already killed him
during avengers infinity war just a little while
ago and brought him back to life so whatever the
marvel mcu and sony plans are for miles morales
in the live-action movies cameos solo movies that
left to be a little bit different from the comics
and the animated spider-man into the spider-verse
movie number four most of you will remember we
already have an mcu miles morales who was a very
little kid during spider-man homecoming that's the
miles morales that tom holland is speaking about
in that clip at the beginning of this video during
spider-man homecoming donald globber's aaron davis
prowler character mentions that he has a nephew
he wants to protect his nephew in the comics is
miles morales they did that during the animated
spider-man into the spider-verse movie too and
if you didn't watch the bonus features from that
there was even a full-blown spider-man homecoming
deleted scene where aaron davis literally calls
miles morales on the phone and has a conversation
with him after he runs into spider-man
that's what i get for helping
excuse me
a human being needs help just do man yeah sorry
miles i'm not gonna make it yeah i'm just stuck
so number three in terms of where we're at
after avengers end game the snap the blip
back and spider-man far from home a lot of people
just assume that when marvel was ready to cast a
version of live-action miles morales he'd be
a teenager and they just used the explanation
that he wasn't snapped in aged five years while
peter parker's spider-man stayed the same age
and that would be the easy way to explain how
they could eventually be in a movie together
and when sony and marvel are ready to stop making
tom holland's spider-man solo movies they'll give
miles morales the spider bite and he'll become
a version of ultimate spider-man in the mcu
and go off to his own solo movie franchise the
animated spider-man into the spider-verse movies
are blowing up miles is more popular than ever
now of course sony wants to do live-action miles
morales movies at some point but what happened
last year though is that sony reportedly signed
tom holland to a bunch of more movies and
crossovers because of all the venom crossover
stuff you've been hearing and all the sinister
six in the new contract with marvel meaning that
he would continue to be spider-man for at
least the next four to five years minimum
probably a little bit beyond that just
to account for future avengers movies
like avengers 5 whatever that winds up
being then avengers secret wars any other
mega crossover movies coming down the road
transport to this planet the fantastic four
affirmative and there's another who was a big help
to me against carnage and venom my friend iron man
affirmative and like i said because miles
morales is so popular right now they even have
the playstation 5 miles morales game coming out
really soon sony does not want to wait 6 years to
introduce miles morales to the live-action movies
so an easy solution to that problem would be just
to introduce a multiverse version of the character
and that would explain how mcu peter parker and he
can both be spider-man at the same time while you
also do a pretty comic book accurate version of a
miles morales origin story with the peter parker
from his earth already having died number two a
lot of people now are also trying to connect dots
and speculate that this is all somehow connected
to those spider-verse rumors from the past week
about them wanting reportedly to do cameos with
tobey maguire and andrew garfield we still don't
know if they're actually going to show up anywhere
in the live-action movies anytime soon but more
speculation here what if miles morales came from
toby maguire's earth and he was the spider-man who
winds up dying passing the mantle to a version of
miles morales that's also another easy way to
explain how miles morales in the movies is much
older than you would expect him to be because
tobey maguire's spider-man if you're going by
toby's real age would be more like an early
40-something spider-man so his version of miles
morales would also be way older than mcu miles
morales it's all just a lot of theories at this
point for how sony and marvel want to handle the
spider-verse of it all in the live-action movies
we know more about how the animated spider-man and
the spider-verse movies are connecting all those
live-action movies like tom holland said also in
that clip i was supposed to be in it there was
going to be a train station scene they actually
put a version of that scene in the spider-man
into the spider-verse trailer if you don't
remember it but right now there's no indication
that kevin feige and the mcu people are going to
be referencing the animated movies anytime soon
especially the sony animated movies even though
everybody is a fan of the animated spider-man
of the spider-verse one of the best spider-man
movies of all time there have been recent rumors
that marvel is more open to referencing characters
like venom the live-action version of venom but
that could also just be smaller easter eggs and
multiverse post-credit scene teasers number one
though you also remember there is the clip of tom
holland discussing live-action spider-man into the
spider-verse you may remember watching it back
when they were doing the spiderman far from home
press tour during the video he gets a little weird
as he usually does when he accidentally starts
getting ahead of himself giving away potential
spoilers without one of the other avengers
there or mysterio to stop him those are also
funny compilation videos people trying to stop
tom holland from spoiling things but this is the
clip of him talking about live-action spider-verse
any chance there's a multiverse in which andrew
garfield spider-man and tony maguire spider-man
and spider-man all meet together clashing no
we don't because and then you sort of just say
that everyone just comes from a different
universe but would you want that though
would you want that's maybe that's a better
question we want that i mean as a fan i would
the thing about this film that's so exciting right
is we take spider-man to europe and what's so cool
about that is we've never seen spider-man in
europe before now of course i'd love to make
a movie with those guys it's just so cool now
it'd be amazing it would be really really cool
and it's something that the fans really want
so whether marvel and sony decide to do that um
it's not up to me i can't walk him like kevin
this is what we're doing on the next one yeah
but it would be really awesome so trying to read
between the lines a little bit early speculation
it just sounds like at some point in spider-man
3 we'll see them start to reference more legit
multiverse easter eggs in some way doctor
strange is going to be a big crossover character
in the movie so post all your live-action
spider-verse theories in the comments below
there are multiple realities peter this
is earth dimension 616. i'm from earth-833
i'm sorry you're saying there's a multiverse
what's going to happen next is is i'll post my
video for the new mandalorian season 2 trailer
that should drop by monday night depending on
when you're seeing this video and the mandalorian
season 2 episodes will be starting in a couple
weeks i'll be doing videos for everything
so as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you'll see all those videos when i
post them congratulations divine sonic you're
the giveaway winner from my last big spider-man
3 video please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your contact details that's
on the desktop youtube site everyone click here
for my big spider-man 3 toby mcguire andrew
garfield video and click here for that new
mandalorian season 2 trailer thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!